what important idea do you believe is
true
that
many others uh don't agree with you on
maybe uh it's a tough question you might
have to think about that one but it was
very specific
like which material to use or something
about a particular project
or um
it could be grand priorities on missions
i think one you actually mentioned is
interesting is like
um the thing we should be looking for is
like colonization of space versus
colonization of planets
meaning like
uh my best hot take that people would
disagree with me on is
life in floating cities as opposed to
life on
on the surface how do you envision that
like
spread of humans because you said at the
beginning of the conversation something
about like
scale increasing the scale of basically
humans in space are they just
like in um they're in orbit and then
they get a little farther and farther
out like do you see this kind of
uh
floating cities just getting farther and
far from earth they can always kind of
return but like if you look a few
centuries from now do you just see us
all these like floating
yes
and it just kind of envelops
uh the space around us
and it's like neighborhoods like yeah
yeah it's like rural and there's like
giant structures and there's small
pirate structures and that kind of stuff
structures yeah i think low earth orbit
might come to look like that and it's a
really interesting regulatory challenge
to make sure that um there's some cross
purposes so the more cool space it is we
have in orbit the more shiny objects in
the night sky the worse it is for
astronomers in a really kind of overly
simplified case
so there's some push back to this like
amoeba-ing where we just grow kind of um
incongruously or indiscriminately as an
amoeba in low-earth orbit beyond that
though i think we'll grow in pockets
where there are resources so we won't
just expand around the gravity well of
earth
we'll do
some development around the moon some
development around asteroids some
development around mars because there'll
always be purposes for which we want to
go down to a physical object and study
it or extract something or learn from it
but i think we'll grow in fits and
starts in pockets um some of the coolest
pockets are the gravity balanced pockets
like the lagrange points which is where
we just sent we not me personally but
nasa just sent uh james webb
the big telescope i think it's at l2
so uh what's the nice feature about
those pockets so it's a stable orbit um
there are several different lagrange
points and so it just requires less
energy to stay where you're trying to
stay
yeah
that's fascinating what's also
fascinating is the interaction between
nations
regard like who owns that do you would
you would you say in those floating
cities do you envision
independent governments
that was going to be my next answer to
you which pushed me harder for a more
provocative question where i might
disagree with other people i don't yet
have my own opinions fully formed on
this but we are trying to figure out
right now what happens to the moon with
all of these first-come first-served
actors just arriving and setting
precedence that might really affect
future access and one example is
property rights we do want companies
that have the expertise to go to the
moon and mine stuff that will help us
uh you know develop a human settlement
there or a gateway but companies need to
know generally that they have rights to
a certain area or that they have some
legal right to sell things that they're
getting does that mean we're going to
grant property rights on the moon to
companies who has the right to give that
right away so there's a bunch of really
kind of gnarly questions that we have to
think about which is why i think we need
space lawyers maybe that's the true
provocative answer is i think we need
space
i mean yeah yeah i mean but those
questions again as you said
eloquently will help us answer questions
about here we hope so yeah it is a
little
strange
i mean it's obvious but it's also
strange if you look at the big picture
of it all that we draw these like
borders around geographical areas and we
say this is mine
like and then we fight wars over what's
mine and not there there it seems like
they're
there's possible alternatives but also
it seems like
there needs to be a public ownership of
some parts
um like you know what is it central park
in new york is there something
like
preserving commons yeah the commons
commons that's why we titled the book
into the anthropo cosmos we know it's a
long kind of a mouthful but this notion
of the anthropocene
uh we have a lot of commons problems in
humanity how are we treating the earth
global climate change how are we going
to treat and behave in space how can we
be responsible stewards of the space
commons and i would love to see an
approach to the moon that is commons
based but it's hard to know who would be
the protector or the enforcer of that
and if it's which it will be probably in
the early days a lot of companies sort
of working on the moon working on mars
working out in space
it feels like there still needs to be
a civilian representation
of like the greater effort or something
like that like where there should be a
president there should be a democracy
yeah of some kind where people can vote
some representative government those all
again same the same human questions
you